que cette crise puisse être une opportunité pour la Grèce, pour l'Europe,
pour le monde, de faire des transformations démocratiques radicales
dans nos institutions.
Au lieu de cela, j'ai eu une expérience très humiliante.
À Bruxelles, lorsque nous avons essayé désespérément encore et encore
de trouver des solutions communes,
je me suis rendu compte que pas un, pas un de nous,
n'avait jamais dû s'occuper d'une crise similaire.
Mais pire encore, nous étions pris au piège par notre ignorance collective.
Nous étions menés par nos peurs.
Et nos craintes nous ont conduits à une foi aveugle
dans l'orthodoxie de l'austérité.
Au lieu de tendre la main à la sagesse
commune ou collective dans nos sociétés,
investir pour trouver des solutions plus créatives,
nous sommes retombés sur les manœuvres politiques.
Et puis nous nous sommes surpris quand chaque
nouvelle mesure spécial ne mettait pas un terme à la crise,
et bien sûr cela rendait très facile
la recherche d'un bouc émissaire
pour notre échec collectif européen,
et bien sûr, c'était la Grèce.
Ces Grecs gaspilleurs, oisifs, buveurs d'Ouzo, danseurs de Zorba,
ce sont eux le problème. Punissez-les !
Eh bien, un stéréotype pratique mais non fondé
qui parfois blessent plus que l''austérité-même.
Mais je vous préviens, ce n'est pas que la Grèce.
Ça pourrait être le modèle
que les dirigeants suivent encore et encore
lorsque nous traitons ces problèmes complexes, internationales,
que ce soit le changement climatique, que ce soit l'immigration,
que ce soit le système financier.
C'est abandonner notre pouvoir collectif
d'imaginer notre potentiel,
être victimes de nos peurs, de nos stéréotypes, de nos dogmes,
sortir les citoyens du processus
plutôt que de construire le processus autour des citoyens.
Et faire cela testera uniquement la foi
de nos concitoyens, de notre peuple, encore plus
dans le processus démocratique.
Ce n'est pas étonnant que de nombreux dirigeants politiques,
et je ne m'exclus pas,
ont perdu la confiance du peuple.
Quand la police anti-émeute doit protéger les parlements,
une scène qui est de plus en plus courante dans le monde entier,
il y a un mal profond dans nos démocraties.
C'est pourquoi j'ai demandé un référendum pour que le peuple grec
possède et définisse les termes du plan de sauvetage.
Mes homologues européens, certains d'entre eux du moins,
ont dit: « Tu ne peux pas faire ça.
Il y aura à nouveau le chaos dans les marchés. »
J’ai dit, « Nous devons le faire, avant de restaurer la confiance des marchés,
nous devons restaurer la confiance du peuple. »
Après avoir quitté le bureau, j'ai eu le temps de réfléchir.
Nous avons résisté à la tempête, en Grèce et en Europe,
mais les défis continuent.
Si la politique est le pouvoir d'imaginer et d'utiliser notre potentiel,
le taux de chômage à 60% des jeunes en Grèce,
et dans d'autres pays, est certainement le signe d'un manque d'imagination
si ce n'est pas un manque de compassion.
Jusqu'ici, nous avons inculpé l'économie,
en fait surtout l'austérité,
et nous aurions certainement pu concevoir des alternatives,
une stratégie différente, un stimulus vert pour des emplois verts,
ou la dette mutualisée, les euro-obligations
qui soutiendraient les besoins des pays sujets aux pressions des marchés,
ça aurait pu être une alternative beaucoup plus viable.
Pourtant, j'en suis arrivé à croire que le problème n'est pas plus
un problème d'économie qu'un problème de démocratie.
Essayons donc autre chose.
Voyons comment ramener les gens dans le processus.
Considerons la démocratie dans le problème.
Encore une fois, la Grèce antique, avec toutes ses imperfections,
croyait en la sagesse de la foule
dans ses meilleurs moments. Nous faisons confiance aux gens.
La démocratie ne pourrait pas marcher sans les citoyens
qui délibèrent, débattent, prennent des responsabilités publiques
pour les affaires publiques.
Les citoyens moyens, étaient souvent choisis pour les jurys citoyens
pour se prononcer sur les questions critiques de la journée.
Science, théâtre, recherche, philosophie,
jeux de l'esprit et du corps,
c'était des exercices quotidiens.
En fait, c'était une éducation à la participation,
pour la croissance du potentiel des citoyens.
Et ceux qui ont boudé la politique, eh bien, c'était des idiots.
Vous voyez, dans la Grèce antique, dans l'Athènes antique,
ce terme provient de là.
« Idiot » vient de la racine « idio », soi-même.
Une personne qui est égocentrique, isolée, exclue,
quelqu'un qui ne participe pas ou n'examine pas les affaires publiques.
Et la participation se déroulait dans l'agora, qui a deux significations,
c'est à la fois un marché et un endroit de délibération politique.
Vous voyez, les marchés et la politique ont été ensuite un seul, unifiés,
accessibles, transparents, parce qu'ils donnaient le pouvoir au peuple.
Ils servent la démocratie.
Au-dessus de gouvernement, au-dessus des marchés
il y avait la loi directe du peuple.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons mondialisé les marchés
mais nous n'avons pas globalisé nos institutions démocratiques.
Donc nos politiciens sont limités à la politique locale,
alors que nos concitoyens, même s'ils voient un grand potentiel,
sont la proie de forces qui échappent à leur contrôle.
Donc comment réunir les deux moitiés de l'agora ?
Comment démocratiser la mondialisation ?
Et je ne parle pas des réformes nécessaires
des Nations Unies ou du G20.
Je parle de comment assurer l'espace,
la démocratie, la base de valeurs,
afin de puiser dans tout votre potentiel ?
Eh bien, je crois que c'est exactement là que s'inscrit l'Europe.
L'Europe, malgré ses échecs récents,
est l'expérience de paix entre pays la plus réussie du monde.
Voyons donc si elle peut ne pas être une expérience
dans la démocratie mondiale, une nouvelle forme de démocratie.
Voyons si nous ne pouvons pas concevoir une agora européenne,
pas simplement pour les produits et les services,
mais pour nos concitoyens, où ils puissent travailler ensemble,
délibérer, apprendre les uns des autres,
échanger entre l'art et les cultures,
où ils peuvent trouver des solutions créatives.
Imaginons que les citoyens européens
aient réellement le pouvoir de voter directement
pour un président européen,
ou des jurys de citoyens choisis par tirage au sort
qui peuvent délibérer sur les questions critiques et controversées,
un référendum européen où nos concitoyens,
comme les députés, votent sur les futurs traités.
Et voici une idée :
pourquoi ne pas avoir les premiers citoyens véritablement européens
en donnant à nos immigrés,
non pas la citoyenneté grecque ou allemand ou suédoise,
mais une citoyenneté européenne ?
Et veillons à responsabiliser vraiment
les chômeurs en leur donnant des bons d'achat, des bourses
pour qu'ils puissent choisir d'étudier n'importe où en Europe.
Où notre identité commune est la démocratie,
où notre instruction se fait par le biais de la participation,
et où la participation inspire confiance
et solidarité plutôt qu'exclusion et xénophobie.
Europe de et par le peuple,
une Europe, une expérience d'approfondissement et d'élargissement
de la démocratie au-delà des frontières.
Maintenant, certains pourraient m'accuser d'être naïf,
en mettant ma foi dans la puissance et la sagesse du peuple.
Eh bien, après des décennies dans la vie politique, je suis aussi un pragmatique.
Croyez-moi, j'ai fait,
je fais partie du système politique d'aujourd'hui,
et je sais que les choses doivent changer.
Nous devons relancer la politique comme un pouvoir d'imaginer,
réinventer et reconcevoir un monde meilleur.
Mais je sais aussi que cette force de changement perturbatrice
ne sera pas pilotée par la politique d'aujourd'hui.
Le renouveau de la politique démocratique
viendra de vous, et je veux dire de chacun d'entre vous.
Tous ceux qui participent à l'échange mondial d'idées,
qu'il s'agisse d'ici dans cette salle
ou juste en dehors de cette salle,
ou en ligne ou localement, où tout le monde vit,
tous ceux qui résistent à l'injustice et à l'inégalité,
tous ceux qui résistent à ceux qui prêchent
le racisme plutôt que l'empathie,
les dogmes plutôt que la pensée critique,
la technocratie plutôt que la démocratie,
tous ceux qui se lèvent contre le pouvoir incontrôlé,
que ce soit des dirigeants autoritaires,
des ploutocrates qui cachent leurs avoirs dans des paradis fiscaux,
ou les puissantes lobbies qui protègent les quelques puissants.
C'est dans leur intérêt que nous sommes tous des idiots.
Ne le soyons pas.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Vous semblez décrire un leadership politique
qui n'est pas prêt
et prisonnier des caprices des marchés financiers,
et cette scène à Bruxelles que vous décrivez,
pour moi, en tant que citoyen, est terrifiante.
Aidez-nous à comprendre ce que vous avez ressenti après la décision.
Ce n’était pas une bonne décision, c'est clair
mais comment vous sentez-vous après cela, non pas en tant que premier ministre,
mais en tant que George ?
George Papandreou : Eh bien, évidemment il y avait des contraintes
qui ne me permettaient pas à moi ou à d'autres de prendre
les types de décisions, que nous aurions souhaité,
et évidemment, j'avais espéré que nous aurions le temps
de faire les réformes qui auraient réglé
le déficit, plutôt que d'essayer de réduire le déficit
qui était le symptôme du problème.
Et ça fait mal. Ça fait mal parce que, tout d'abord,
cela blesse les jeunes générations et pas seulement,
beaucoup d'entre eux manifestent,
mais je pense que c'est un de nos problèmes.
Lorsque nous sommes confrontés à ces crises, nous excluons le potentiel,
l'énorme potentiel de notre société de ce processus,
et nous nous enfermons dans la vie politique,
et je pense que nous devons changer cela, trouver vraiment
de nouvelles façons participatives grâce aux grandes capacités
qui existent maintenant, technologiques, mais pas seulement,
les esprits que nous avons, et je pense que nous pouvons trouver des solutions
qui sont beaucoup mieux, mais nous devons être ouverts.
BG : Vous semblez suggérer que la démarche à suivre
est plus européenne, et cela ne va pas être simple
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des pays européens.
C'est plutôt l'inverse -- plus de frontières fermées
et moins de coopération et peut-être même renoncer
à certaines parties de la construction européenne.
Comment conciliez-vous cela ?
GP : Eh bien, je pense que l'une des pires choses qui s'est passée
pendant cette crise est que nous avons commencé un jeu de responsabilité.
Et l'idée fondamentale de l'Europe est que
nous pouvons coopérer au-delà des frontières,
aller au-delà de nos conflits et travailler ensemble.
Et le paradoxe est que, parce que nous avons ce jeu de responsabilité,
nous sommes moins susceptibles de convaincre nos concitoyens
que nous devrions travailler ensemble,
alors que le moment est venu
de rassembler nos compétences.
Plus d'Europe pour moi ce n'est pas simplement
donner plus de pouvoir à Bruxelles.
C'est donner plus de pouvoir aux citoyens de l'Europe,
c'est faire de l'Europe un projet du peuple.
Ce serait une façon de répondre à
certaines des craintes que nous avons dans notre société.
BG : George, merci d'être venus à TED.
GP : Merci beaucoup. BG : Merci. (Applaudissements)